>> Sean: SARAH, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE FAMILY PAIRED WE
ARE GLAD TO HAVE YOU.
YOU WENT OUT ON A LIMB FOR HIM
ALSO.
THERE'S A FEW OF US.
NOT MANY.
AND LOOK WHAT HE'S DONE.
TAX CUTS.
BIGGEST IN THE NATION'S HISTORY.
DEREGULATION.
LARGEST IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
GETTING THE MONEY TO BUILD THE
BORDER WALL'S.
GOT IT.
NANCY PELOSI'S PRETTY TICKED
OFF.
TRADE DEALS WITH JAPAN, CANADA,
MEXICO, WESTERN EUROPEAN ALLIES.
CHINA IS NOW AT A 27 YEAR LOW IN
TERMS OF THEIR ECONOMY.
AN 11 YEAR LOW IN THEIR
CURRENCY.
I'D SAY THERE'S A LOT OF WINNING
IN THERE.
>> Newt: THERE'S A LOT OF
WINNING.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT NO MATTER WHAT
THE NEWS MEDIA DOES, THERE'S A
CORE BASED IN 44-45% OF THE
COUNTRY, THAT FRANKLY IGNORES
ALL THE NOISE, FOCUSES ON WHAT'S
WORKING, NOTICES, FOR EXAMPLE,
LOWEST BLOCK ON EMPLOYMENT IN
HISTORY, LOWEST LATINO
UNEMPLOYMENT IN HISTORY.
LOWEST FEMALE UNEMPLOYMENT IN
HISTORY.
THEY LOOK AT THAT, AND THEY SAY,
THIS IS A PRETTY GOOD DEAL.
A COMBINATION OF WAGES GOING UP
AND THE TAX CUTS.
AGAIN, YOU GOT PEOPLE LOOKING
AROUND THINKING, THIS IS ALL
WORKING.
AND THEN THEY WATCH THE DEMO THE
DEMOCRATS, MISSING BASICALLY TO
DESTROY IT.
YOU HAVE A CONTRAST THAT IS THIS
WIDE BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
MAKE AMERICA WORK AND PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO DESTROY.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE SORT OF
CORE UNDERLYING THEME.
>> Sean: COMING BACK FROM A
LONG VACATION.
THEY GOT BEATEN UP PRETTY BAD.
THE MUELLER REPORT.
THEY PUT SO MUCH FAITH, HOPE,
AND TRUST.
IT DIDN'T COME BACK THE WAY THEY
WANTED.
EVEN IF IT MEANS SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS THAT ARE IN A TRUMP
DOMINATED DISTRICT.
EVEN IF THEY LOSE AND KNOWING
THE SENATE WILL NEVER GO ALONG.
IS THERE ANY ONE THING THAT THEY
ARE ADVOCATING FOR TO ADVANCE
THE CONDITION OF THIS COUNTRY,
HELP PEOPLE GET JOBS, BUILD THE
ECONOMY, CREATE A SAFER COUNTRY
FOR US?
I CAN'T THINK OF ANY.
THE NEW GREEN DEAL DOESN'T CUT
IT FOR ME.
>> Newt: [LAUGHS]
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE INDIVIDUAL
DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE IDEAS THAT
ARE INTERESTING.
SOME OF THE NEWER AND YOUNGER
MEMBERS.
BUT OVERALL, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS FALLEN OFF
A CLIFF.
JUST TAKE THE EXAMPLE OF
ELIZABETH WARREN, PROMISING THAT
SHE WILL MAKE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TO BAN ALL FRACKING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
FRACKING IS A TECHNOLOGY, WHICH
HAS ENABLED US TO BECOME THE
BIGGEST PRODUCER OF OIL IN THE
WORLD.
IT HAS RE-CREATED THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY IN AMERICA.
THIS IS A VERY HIGH INCOME
INDUSTRY.
IT HAS HELPED US ADVANCE THE
RUSSIANS AND THE SAUDIS AND THE
IRRADIANCE.
SHE COMES ALONG, AND I DON'T
THINK THE DEMOCRATS REALIZE,
THERE'S GOING TO BE COUNTY AFTER
COUNTY AFTER COUNTY.
EASTERN OHIO, WESTERN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS WERE
MAKING A LIVING BECAUSE OF WHAT
HAS HAPPENED WITH FRACKING.
AND BASICALLY, SHE'S THE
GUARANTEED UNEMPLOYMENT
CANDIDATE.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THE DEMOCRATS
RUNNING INTO THESE KIND OF
THINGS AS A GROUP.
IT'S THE MOST LEFT-WING GROUP
I'VE EVER SEEN.
>> Sean: LOOK.
THE NEW GREEN DEAL WOULD BE AN
ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE.
NO FAITH IN JOE 30330.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO SEE HIS
MEDICAL RECORDS.
WHATEVER THEY ARE, KEEP THEM
PRIVATE.
I'M LOOKING AT A GUY WHO IS AGED
LIKE 20 YEARS SINCE HE LEFT
OFFICE.
HE HAS NO ENERGY, NO, IF YOU
WANT TO BE PRESIDENT, YOU RUN
FOR PRESIDENT.
YOU BETTER HAVE YOUR A GAME ON.
YOU BETTER HAVE YOUR ENERGY
LEVEL UP.
COFFEE'S NOT GOING TO CUT IT.
YOU GOT TO HAVE THE PASSION TO
DO IT.
>> Newt: I THINK THAT BIDEN'S
ALMOST SAD.
YOU WATCH HIM, AND I FIND MYSELF
FLINCHING, BECAUSE YOU'RE
WATCHING A GUY WHO CLEARLY
SHOULD IT BE IN THE ARENA
ANYMORE.
I'M NOT SURE HE EVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN, BECAUSE TWICE BEFORE, HE
HAD TO DROP OUT AS A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, BECAUSE
HE JUST COULDN'T DO IT.
BUT WASHINGTON, NOW, AT THIS
POINT IN HIS CAREER, AND
WASHINGTON MAKE MISTAKE AFTER
MISTAKE AFTER MISTAKE, YOU KNOW,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
THAT IN A THREE MINUTE PERIOD,
HE MADE SEVEN ERRORS.
NOW, IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT,
SEVEN MAJOR ERRORS IN 3 MINUTES
YOU HAVE A BIG PROBLEM.
>> Sean: HE LOST
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST."